all right friends so as you know or you
may not know I'm in the middle of a cut
I am running a barbell Brigade get lean
program and I'm competing against BART
to see who can get the leanest lose the
most body fat and before you go well
wait guys and girls don't need to lose
uh calories at the same rate
100 correct nor does person to person
lose calories or fat the exact same way
nor do we store it the same way we're
all so different so we're not going
based off of calories we're going based
off of body fat percentage that we lose
um from the beginning of of this
competition and as you also know we're
in the middle of a move because I've
been like talking about it this entire
[ __ ] Vlog what am I talking about I
am so brain dead anyway so it's really
easy to be like you know what I've been
moving all week or two weeks or whatever
and like I have no food I have basically
I'm making excuses it's really easy to
fall into that and be like oh I deserve
it I'm so sad right now oh I'm so
stressed and that's fine we're all
humans we all feel the exact same
emotions right
but here is where I don't want you to
deviate from your goals what is the big
picture and what does that look like
don't fall victim to how you feel right
now and make decisions as you're going
uphill don't do that because for sure
you're gonna fall victim to the now to
the emotion and you're gonna forget
about that goal and you might never
reach that goal so I always want to
practice what I preach and um I don't
have any food at my house as you guys
saw it's empty I don't have anything so
it's it's easy for me to go against
tracking my macros trying to hit my
macros and go you know what it's going
to be more convenient and easy if I just
order McDonald's or if I just kind of
eyeball it or I don't plug in my numbers
like it's just gonna be so easy right
wrong I have a big picture goal in mind
I do want to feel strong look good feel
capable there's just too many fitness
goals that I have right now that I just
don't want to let my future self down so
I want to recommend this spot if you're
from Vegas again not sponsored I just
really like promoting quality things to
you to you
so if you're in Vegas
um there's this place up here or here
called foodie fit and they really do
cater to the healthy lifestyle or the
healthier Alternatives of you know all
the food that we love so this is what
I'm picking up for lunch the funny thing
is
um I'm picking up in and out for my mom
and taika because they just I mean it's
taika and it's my mom and they want what
they want you know what I mean they
don't want to do the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
I'm doing right now in this cut so I got
myself let me show you what it looks
like
I got myself a blueberry parface so it's
yogurt blueberry compote compote compo
compote compote compote anyway crumbled
oats um and oh it doesn't have the
macros on here but normally they have
macros
um the macros are really good I also got
a Kelly hash for tomorrow's breakfast so
it's 480 calories 45 protein 32 carb and
18 fats so I got my breakfast for
tomorrow and then for today's lunch I'm
gonna have
um asada steak plate so the protein is
60 [ __ ] grams 42 carbs 11 fats
and then maybe for another meal today
who knows I wanted to keep its light so
31 carb 40 protein and 11 grams of fat
for a usual whoops usual day for me is
about
um my macros right now are 40 fats 115
carbs oh so sad
um and
and 170 proteins as you can see if I eat
two of those meals I'm already at 100
um
so like I can easily hit my my macros
you know with those couple of meals that
I just showed you so no excuses you guys
don't make decisions when you're going
uphill okay that's the worst time to
make a decision the best time to make a
decision is when you're neutral when
you're at a good spot not suffering not
too happy not too sad just neutral so
hopefully this serves as a little
reminder to focus on your goals don't
let the noise in your head get in the
way of the big picture Vision okay like
don't let your future self down if you
want to if you want to gain confidence
you have to make promises to yourself
and you have to keep those promises and
the more that you can do that and the
more you can practice that the more your
confidence and self-love and all of that
is going to grow trust me okay back to
the regularly scheduled program and
because I'm hungry
look at this deliciousness oh my God
this one's like this little Burger
monkey is it delicious taika
is it delicious
[Music]
he's so rude
Bart's son oh sure
well let me warm up my food
and just like
that
see you later home
[Music]
thank you for zero memories just kidding
you're beautiful but not for us
thank you baby
peace
okay so now I am charging my car just to
make sure I have a full not tank but a
full battery
so we are at the only place that is not
on the Strip there's literally like
almost nothing out here in terms of
supercharging there's just these two how
ridiculous big is what the heck
so we're at tavoli Village and as we
were exploring we saw something huh
okay let's see what we find oh it's
right there but you guys can't see
anything
so that is what we saw when we were just
exploring
because my car is over there
oh and my boy is over here
at you okay let's go see what's
happening
even though your mom looks like trash
we'll make it work is that funny
[Applause]
it's like a craft market look at that
all the food trucks
huh
yeah and there's all this stuff how cool
like is about to buy something really
CUNY
yeah okay ready yeah okay
thank you very much sir you're welcome
thank you can I see oh that's so cool
kind of creepy
you know what the purpose of slugs are
so now we are getting honey sticks but
these are infused with flavors which
flavors are you getting uh this one's
blueberry
chocolate
sour apple sour apples sour cherry
pink lemonade
lemonade
[Applause]
okay so you're eating a honey stick what
flavor is that
lemonade
pink lemonade
how do you like it it kind of looks like
blood yeah a little bit is it yummy
that's it that's all I get
we have an escalator which means this
guy has to go down
and up
and it was Grandma's idea this time
so now they're going down
they're dancing okay
and now
they're gonna come back up
I hope
there they go
oh he's back
take us back
hey if you get stuck
Thank you Grandma
I'm letting the car drive itself
oh I admire
take this beautiful voice but also
look at this scenery
yeah Grandma answer him
and check out this car it is packed to
The Very Room it's like where are you
there you are
but that's it that's the last of
everything tomorrow
done that's cool
that's cool the house is done
and we showered had some lunch linner
lunch dinner like a late lunch early
dinner and now we are at Red Rock Casino
because I'm gonna take taika bowling and
we're actually gonna meet up with Anna
Christina finally who have been living
here maybe a month now we haven't seen
them yet because we've just been so
slammed both of us moving here and
removing and all that
um so super stoked to have little monkey
man play with Leia in Enzo and this is
his first time bowling right Duty oh
snap
that's the right place
yeah yeah yeah okay so Red Rock Lane
which is
Saturday and it is eight we don't have
reservations and we feel like everyone
has the same idea so we'll see how it
goes right monkey monks
you get 50 000 points how are you gonna
do that
oh okay
you got this I believe in you
oh yeah those are pins
look at that
whoa whoa
cool let's get Elaine baby
[Laughter]
what's up who's that who is that who is
it look look at say hi say hi thank you
oh my God oh my God oh cute hi
what is this is so cute how much do you
guys miss each other a lot yeah yeah
okay we're vlogging and vlogging but I'm
so happy to see you someone's like
trying to get in on the action she's
like hello
oh my God
I love it I love it
[Applause]
oh my God my ovaries are gonna burst
oh my God
dude
the rest of this Vlog is just gonna be
kid-footed just letting you know okay
look at how cute he is
[Applause]
I love it here I love it I love it I
love it
okay A little detour I gotta go back
home because right now
uh I forgot to bring Tyga's seizure
medicine and he has to take it well in
my books she has to take it at the same
time every single day so we're going
home really quick take his medicine
and then we're gonna come right back
and we're gonna go bowling
because the bowling lane wasn't even
uh they weren't any free yet
so there was like an hour wait anyway so
we're almost at the hour marks I think
by the time we come back
we should be good but
always remember pack taika's seizure
medicine
we're getting used to it baby it's a new
workflow we'll make it work
[Applause]
monkeys you're gonna wear bowling shoes
Duty you have to open it here my love
like this
here I'll open this one for you I'll
open this one I'll open this one you got
a good job
it's Tyga's first time
wait wait is that one too heavy okay do
you know what you're gonna do okay wait
hold wait ready yeah
go there it goes there we go
[Applause]
they
were too happy
you did a good job dude
okay
you gotta see that I'm in here
we go
here okay careful here we go
foreign
it's 11 p.m and I want to say this was a
successful following slash gambling trip
calling it a night had a ton of fun my
heart is full from my body
oh my body this is so tired and I think
it's time to go to bed thank you guys so
much for watching
later
[Applause]